[Music]
am i in the right place
yep
i'm good i'm good no i'm ready
all right um i'm machine gun kelly and
i'm super late
take one
[Music]
and these are my three big fits got your
seat belt
good strap in outfit number one
lately i've been going to a lot of
sporting events i personally
like to just throw off all the toxic
masculinity in the room which it's full
of
by just wearing a kilt
wearing a leather vest putting the white
tee on underneath
this is a whole celine look right here i
mean yeah this just
screams yell at me and possibly throw
your plastic cup of beer as i walk by
which i'm down with shoe eyes these are
celine low tops which would go cool
i also i mean i'm a huge boot guy i
bought these in paris
a couple years ago these are chrome
hearts it's probably gonna get rowdy
when you wear a kilt
so boots for stomping maybe
going with the boots
[Music]
big fit number one insert bagpipes here
thank you inspiration
ace ventura braveheart sex pistols
this is a great fit for any sports event
because
people are going to look they're going
to have their beer they're going to have
their bros they're going to be super
stoked on whatever's happening on the
court or field or ring
they're going to be like oh let's go
let's go all this machine like
what's he wearing dude is that a dress
i'm gonna spill beer on it and then i'm
gonna look at them
with my beautiful girlfriend i'm gonna
go
i'll suck this up
when you're younger you want to wear
things because other people are wearing
them
not really considering how you look
wearing them so like when i would look
and be like oh man
pharrell looks so sick in that the
things that he's wearing were like
colorful bait looks cool
on my skinny hairy legs
they didn't look cool right so like
i wish i could go back and press delete
on some of my outfits
but i'm also you know i own it
it's okay
you can go and ask rick owens any store
from the miami new york to los angeles
one i have
legit probably spent fifty thousand
dollars in
a tanks we don't call them wife beaters
anymore i know this
because i've spent fifty thousand
dollars on them here's one that was
a date night this is a berluti suit i'm
a big turtleneck guy
i have a purple aston martin which was
my dream car because i wanted to be
james bond when i was a kid
so i'm got the suit to match my car
and we stepped out i'm really into moody
colors so
purple pink i like to
put people off a little bit when i step
out and do the juxtaposition of
how all my tattoos look or what people
may think of me
and just go completely against that
stereotype and
wear the most opposite color that you
would associate so you know i would do
like a pink tank under this
pink button up i'm big on custom things
when i was performing in times square
for the new year's eve ball drop
i had this designer ashton michaels just
make i mean these are if
i wish you could feel these these got
to be 35 40 pounds
like here just listen
it doesn't do justice actually to how
heavy they are i i thought it would i
don't know why i thought it would sound
like a hammer but
a little crazy so
strap me in jack you know also
i'm a huge where there's so many of my
clothes that aren't here
like can i have like like my vintage
stuff like the leather
with all the holes in them yeah that's
cool
these are fun stuff like this i wore
this to the ufc
fight recently it it kind of says
hey i'm here to fix your plumbing but
i'm also here to watch a sporting event
i love going into thrift stores and
vintage
shops i've got these
which just screamed wear me
these are my swiss cheese pants
where would you wear those too anywhere
not in the sun because they get very
sweaty this is also something that you
know i could put this on top this is a
is this mosquito this is jeremy scott
this is like when you're lonely and
you're reading a comic book
in a restaurant me all the time but you
want someone to come and just like cheer
you up
you wear this because they're gonna hey
man cool sweater and then just walk away
welcome back do you have your glasses on
cool i hated that
note to editor don't use that big fit
number two
date night i'm gonna be honest with you
a lot of date nights really just consist
of jeans
and a t-shirt but this date night maybe
we're not going to a bar
or a restaurant maybe we're going to
like the top of the eiffel tower so if
that's the case
we're going to pull off something which
i've hated
for years any years and years but we're
gonna try it
and i pray to the fashion gods we don't
fail
the see-through suit gone wrong on many
occasions
example number one marcus houston at the
mtv awards
what the what's that what we're not
gonna do
is wear shorts and a t-shirt under this
we're gonna try
to offset this whole
just eons of terrible clear suits with a
turtleneck
hold your turtlenecks on my thing and
dress pants
this alone very scary this
paired could be a really hot date you
might get your first kiss
square toes and square heels shallow
you've got a winner
good thing about this date night fit is
your date already knows you're coming
she can hear you from the block away
going walking
date night success however don't wear
this
in applebee's you will be the biggest
of all time definitely gotta go
somewhere like the top of the eiffel
tower
mostly so there's other tourists
covering up the noise of your ridiculous
suit
for whenever you lean in on that date
night for a kiss it'll probably sound
like this
i've had a really good night with you
baby me too babe i love you
i love you
sorry sorry it's just my suit just
ignore that
[Music]
mostly real behind the scenes look what
gq doesn't show you
that fly is open my friend and it's not
closing huh
your house is on fire you can save one
out one piece of clothing from
these two racks one outfit to save
this is what i save in a house fire i've
worn this probably 200 times
i was obsessed with neo in the matrix
and how they all dressed in that movie
this is a zion fit rave underground
get all sweaty get a giant metal
tube plugged in your head go fight some
agents do this move
unplug again and eat terrible oatmeal
that they serve and then i just like
a good pair of news article pants this
does serve as like a good
airplane entertainment especially when
like they come on they're like our
entertainment system's broken you're
like
okay at least i have my legs
stuff like this i wore this on my
birthday dinner
these are these pants pretty sure i got
these in like a in a vintage store or a
thrift store so these were somebody
else's pants but
they're not mine and i just paired these
with some
mgk merch so my hair was blue
and i had on this yellow jacket so i was
like
i should probably pair the outfit with
the yellow jacket that's on insert
this is my birthday junior outfit
where'd you go i
a lot of times we'll just be in the
closet
which she mostly dominates all the wall
space so i go in my little corner and
then i have to
fish out stuff and then we'll turn
around and then we'll either be like oh
this
goes great or it'll be like holy one of
us has to change
i think it was me that had to change
this night if you ever want to see
any of my outfits from when i was
younger you can just probably check a
dumpster because they're all trash
that's actually false because like if
there's one thing i wish i could go back
in a dumpster and get it would be my
jenko jeans that i wore
when i was like 11 to 15
and they were like this wide had holes
all in them from skateboarding
and they were jenko jeans dude if you
don't know about janko jeans
look behind the shirt
hey guess what it's the last one
we're going big looks like we're going
to space
this right here is an elon must ladies
and gentlemen
obviously the only place to go in this
is to the moon
look at this look at the crotch area
everything's safe
it's netted
i mean also too you can't be up there
barefoot
shalom if i ever see you
anywhere in life besides the moon
wearing
eight inch orange moon walkers
i'm gonna ask you for a picture
this is machine gun kelly reporting in
for mars um
surprisingly they have really good weed
up here
don't want to say i predicted this in a
quarantine section that i did last year
but i did say spaceships see me when i'm
up yeah
i've been a martian with no elon musk
yeah
and here i am
yeah seriously i would wear this to the
grocery store to buy snacks
and i'm out